we are talking about freeze patterns so
a fleece pattern is a table of numbers
the rule of the game is we start with
the row of once then we'll have more
interesting crows but eventually we want
to end up with their own ones again so I
will do that okay so there is one
parameter in what we are doing the
number of rows 1 2 3 4 here cellular say
4 rows and now I will put some numbers
in the first row and I will start fill
out this table there is only one rule
the rule is that whenever you see a
small diamond like this the product of
these two numbers - the product of this
two numbers must be always 1 w e- and s
is always 1 that's the rule okay what
about do I'll put some random numbers of
course they are not random but at this
point you are not supposed to understand
what they are in the first row and
actually the row is infinite so I put
the seven numbers and then I repeat them
so it's seven periodic okay so it's
should do 1 3 and so on so now we are in
business
using this diamond rule we can start to
fill out this table I will do it myself
but Brady please watch me let's see what
should be here the number here times 1
should be 1 less than this product so 3
minus 1 this should be 2 let's see 1
times 3 minus 1 times 2 is 1
next one here 6 minus 1 5 this should be
5 3 x - 6 1 times 5 5 6 minus 5 1
correct okay here 2 times 2 4
I put 3 here checking 2 times 2 4 minus
1 times 3 3 4 minus 3 1
okay okay here 1 2 minus 1 here 3 4
minus 3 here well this is a big one 7 4
times 2 8 - 7 1 here 2 1 1 1 1 2 3 4 5 6
7
this will also repeat because of the
first row repeats with period 7 so the
next one should be 2 so so far it's been
good we got nice we got integers no
fraction yes I want to point out that a
small miracle has already happened so if
look at this rule this compass rule if
you know three of these numbers you can
always solve for the remaining one for
example suppose you know W e and N and
you want to solve for s so what is s s
is w e minus 1 over n we subtract and we
divide so there is no chance in general
that will stay within positive integers
we divide so in principle this would be
fractions yeah what we should expect in
general if we put rational numbers in
the first row
everything inside should be rational but
I put positive integers and so far
stable than positive injuries that's
already strange all right so let's do a
hard work what should we put here 10
minus 1 divided by 3 3 10 minus 9
what should we put here 15 minus 1 over
2 7 here 3 minus 1 that's 1 here 2 here
21 minus 1 over 4 5 7 minus 1 6 over 2 3
here 1 1 2 3 or 4 5 6 so it should be a
periodic so the next one must be 3 the
miracle continues the miracle continues
you are right and you want the surprise
that it will continue to the end so two
more miracles we expect we expect
positive integers in this row and we
expect this wants to satisfy the compass
rule okay so let me do it a little
faster that would be a 4 that will be 2
that would be one that will be 3 2 I
guess
2 & 1
and it should be periodic so the
previous one just like this one and
finally I hope it all works for minus 3
1 8 minus 7 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 yes right so
you start to wonder what's going on did
you choose magic numbers star well
certainly certainly the numbers were not
random if you change anything at all
randomly it will break completely the
secret has
name its a theorem it's due to two
famous mathematicians one of them
unfortunately and not with us another
alive coxster and convict John Conway
who is a character in your movies
anymore
ever again I was going to study whatever
I thought was interesting so the theorem
explains this phenomenon and actually
gives a complete description complete
classification of free spurtin which
consists of positive integers so again I
remind everyone that there is a
parameter here the number of non-trivial
grows here this number is 4 but in
principle can be handwritten in anything
else so the theorem is not one theorem
but infinitely many theorems one for
each parameter to explain what's going
on I need to draw a polygon which will
have seven sides I will partition this
heptagon into triangles I will
triangulate it by its diagonals I will
draw this diagonal and this diagonal and
maybe this one and possibly this one
okay so now we have five triangles which
make this heptagon and I will write
numbers at every vertex and the number
is the number of adjacent triangles so
for example this vertex has exactly one
triangle adjacent to it so I write one
here
this vs. has four triangles so that is 4
this one has 2 1 3 2 & 2
ok now we have seven numbers if you
examine this first non-trivial row you
will recognize this number starting with
this one I guess 1 3 2 2 1 4 2 and then
we repeated ok so this shape gave video
numbers yes exactly and the brilliant
beautiful theorem of coxeter and Conway
says that this miracle will happen every
time given an M gone with regulated by
diagonals any way we want
it's an interesting question how many
ways I will say something about that and
we put the numbers of
adjacent to every vertex around the
polygon and now we create the first
Cedro which will be an periodic here it
was an was seven and we put these
numbers in the row with period m and
then we start to fill out our a table
using the composite so the claim is that
after n minus 3 non-trivial rows which
all consist of positive integers will
again have robots so that's when you get
back to the ones exactly n minus n minus
3 yes
so that's the way to construct a free
spurtin consisting of positive integers
of with n minus 3 and the theorem is
that they all are obtained this way so
it's a one-to-one correspondence if we
start with the square this gives us
period 4 in horizontal direction and
with 1 Pentagon gives us 5 periodic
pattern with two hexagon 6 periodic with
3 hep hep tag on your edges so but you
can go to higher what probably there is
not enough room for here but it works
for every n maybe we should start with a
square there are exactly two ways to
triangulated by diagonals this is one
way and this is another way and although
one is obtained from another by rotation
we consider them as different so there
should be two different frieze patterns
of period four and width one responding
to this numbers which are one two one
two and two one two one not very
interesting but it works realty check
Pentagon has five different regulations
by diagonals they all look the same
because the numbers which we write form
the same sequence 3 1 2 2 1 but again we
consider this regulation is different so
there are 5 ways to do it
[Music]
so two ways here five ways here maybe
for complete records we should put
triangles which has only one translation
which you don't need to do it so that
you there and the numbers of course I
want one is one hexagon hexagon already
takes some work so this is one to see
builds yeah this is a different kind of
pattern I guess there is one other
collateral pattern like so
that's gonna start giving us quite
different numbers isn't that is correct
[Music]
you
[Music]
if you are willing to believe me the
number will be 14 here and actually the
sequence 1 2 5 14 this is a famous
sequence which you can find everywhere
and these are Catalan numbers and there
are all over mathematics all over
kinetics there are many many many
interpretations this is just one of the
most common ones sure the next one I
guess is 42 and this is a heptagon
they should be heptagon yes indeed so
does that mean as their polygons get
bigger they'll give us different
families of our fries seeding numbers
that is correct yes the first row will
depend on n as an end gone so it will be
n periodic and on the triangulation
different angulations give us a
different seed rows so I want to make a
for road sandwich yes
ok I'm one of these four row sandwiches
obviously I have to use a heptagon
correct but I will have different ways
to see that depending on how i
triangulated my exactly right exactly
right so in this example we chose one
particular energy regulation but for
example you can choose one of the
diagonals let's say this one you raise
it and replace for example by this one
and that would be a different three
special different relations the numbers
will change as well this will always
work now for every triangulation of will
always give me fries numbers that this
will always works work and this is the
only thing which will work so the
theorem is that if you want a free
spurton consisting of positive integers
you should do this and they're all will
be obtained this way so there's no
chance that I could devise a sequence
that won't come from a triangulation
absolutely not absolutely not you don't
want to see the proof but it says it's a
theorem so as I prove it hundred percent
certain yes amazing it's amazing but you
it takes two geniuses you know coxeter
and conway it's not just any random
pyramid magicians yeah it's really
beautiful maybe I should say a few words
about the
place of the subject occupies in
contemporary mathematics
so when coxeter and Conway came up with
their result and when Congress reduced
arias patterns it seemed like a marginal
subject in some sense I mean there are
many beautiful things in the matrix
which do not belong to mainstream
fortunately for the subject fortunately
for all of us now it's really mainstream
so there is a new relatively new a
theory called theory of cluster algebras
and this is about 20 years old and this
crease patterns occupy a very vulnerable
position in this field is one of the
main examples so they're very much
studied nowadays and they are very
popular if you google the subject you
will see many many scientific papers on
this subject so the intuition of coxeter
and Conway proved itself excellent they
recognized the beauty and now it's
important to to see even more from this
interview including the find lightning
bolt in phrase patterns have a look at
our extra footage channel numberphile -
there'll be a link on the screen and in
the description
this video was filmed at the
mathematical sciences research institute
or msri if you'd like to find out more
about MSR I have a listen to our podcast
episode with the director of the
Institute
David Eisenbud again links are on the
screen and down in the description